let's jump into the first story greta
tunberg effigies
burned in delhi after tweets on farmer's
protests
celebrity interventions in flame
sentiments in india
as police investigate pro farmer's tool
kit
so basically what happened is a couple
weeks ago greta tunberg
accidentally tweeted out what's called
the tool kit it's it's basically just
a manual explaining what to say where to
say it how to do all this stuff
a lot of people find this to be
particularly nefarious they call it
well they say it's similar to
astroturfing do you guys know what
astroturfing is
i've heard of it familiar i've heard it
what is it so
so basically you'll have these big
organizations special interests that
want to get activists to do a thing
and so they'll hire a bunch of people to
show up
and wave signs sometimes it won't be as
direct as saying like we want to pay an
activist
to do this like hardcore astroturfing
the most nefarious would be getting
random people who don't care about the
politics to waive a sign
but typically what it is they'll put up
an ad saying like hey do you care about
climate change well then come on down
and protest and you'll get your food and
travel
paid for and essentially those funds
being provided to activists
allows them the ability to be there it's
considered
inorganic right yeah so when you have
greta toomberg putting out this tool kit
where it's basically telling people what
to say
or how to say it how to protect yourself
and things like that a lot of people
view that as nefarious so now you have
well greta tunberg leaked this they say
this from the guardian
tuna became became embroiled in
allegations of an international criminal
conspiracy against india
after she tweeted a toolkit for people
who wanted to show support
for the farmer so there's a big pharma
products going on right now the document
included campaigning tips
such as suggested hashtags and advice on
how to sign petitions
though not named in the police case that
was filed toonberg's tweet
was said to have brought the delhi
police's attention to the existence of
the toolkit
leaders in the ruling bharatiya janata
party
said the toolkit was evidence of
international plans
for attacks against india now i'm just
going to say this because i know a lot
of people are like whoa greta tuneburg
is caught she's astroturfing
i don't think it's that big of a deal
like if if you
say like hey here's the message we're
using here's the hashtags we're using
and you're telling someone how to get
active
i don't think that's that big of a deal
but i do think it's interesting the way
delhi is handling it they're basically
saying
international you know foreign
celebrities interfering in our politics
ain't going to have none of that so
greta tunberg they're just burning
images of
of her and effigy but here's here's
actually the the the big news
not this one it's the next one indian
activists arrested
for creating protest tool kit shared by
greta tunberg
this is this is a huge huge screw-up on
greta's part look
how old is she now greta tuneburg 18.
i'm not i don't i don't want to uh you
know drag her too heavily
because she's inexperienced and naive
but this was such a
serious failure of operational security
this woman
is facing i think she's facing like life
in prison let's check out the story they
say
desho ravi 22 could face up to life in
prison
following her arrest sunday in
connection to the online document
which calls for organized support for
india's deadly farmers protests
ravi a leader of the indian arm of
tunburg's fridays for future protest
movement
is being investigated for possible
sedition a charge that carries a penalty
of life imprisonment
a police source told reuters well you
know look
i just heard a lot from democrats about
the dangers of insurrection and sedition
and you know they say these people
should be locked up so uh
what's the difference what's the what's
the difference in this story it sounds
like a precedent was set over here in
the u.s and now other countries are
going to take that
and make it totalitarian that's
dangerous that's what they do yeah
often when we see this happen in the u.s
something happened in the us other
countries go okay then we can do it too
right
and so that's actually criticism that
was levied at donald trump they were
saying that when he was going after the
press all of a sudden a bunch of other
world leaders started going after the
press too
i think that's kind of silly you know
criticize people if they do something
wrong
trump expressing his opinions on the
media i don't whatever people have
opinions on the media in other countries
like turkey where they're arresting
generals
the guy i was thinking of erdogan that's
that's turkey arrests more journalists
than anybody else
so here so for those that aren't
familiar with what's going on in in
india
i i just did a quick run through uh
earlier it it's really complicated
complicated i don't know too much but
it's basically a bunch of farmers
have this system where it's they have
like guaranteed pricing from the
government on the crops they grow
so it sustains them and there's a
there's new laws that are coming in
that'll basically take that away
and so they're protesting and this makes
a lot of sense as to why the left is
getting involved and saying
support the farmers because the farmers
want a guaranteed minimum government
intervention over the work they're doing
and the new laws would be more i guess
capitalist according to cnn
they'd be allowed to sell whatever they
grow to whoever
wants that whereas right now the
government guarantees a set minimum
price
and only certain people are allowed to
bid on these crops
the deregu i guess you can call it
deregulation this resulting in these
massive deadly protests
greta tunber gets involved for what
reason i don't really know
now you've got some woman who's facing
uh life in prison
well i don't think anyone should ever be
arrested for posting
anything online especially when it comes
to activist toolkits but
when you look at the larger kind of
international efforts especially by
massively funded pr campaigns there's a
lot of ties between intelligence
agencies and also
the supposed popular uprisings that
usually work in the benefit of american
geopolitics like we saw in ukraine
syria and libya that were very organized
that did have talking points hashtags
and also the coordination of the media
that pushed for a certain agenda and was
able to get it because of these larger
disinformation efforts
and if you study things like the
economic hitman you see these efforts
of an economic immigrant yeah
confessions of an economic hit man
great book definitely recommend you read
it i read it in high school it changed
my vision of the world
when you look at the kind of ways that
they push
for under rest in order to get to their
way it really makes you think
what's really going on here and we have
seen a lot of pressure
uh on india by individuals like bill
gates that are criticizing india
also just recently they're manufacturing
plants so you know there is
there's something to wonder here about
what's happening on the global scale
whether it's a conspiracy or not we do
not
know but i i still think it's
overreaction for india to arrest a
person for for sharing this
and it's only going to hurt them in the
long run i was in india before i got
some wild stories there
i actually landed in india when they did
a currency reset and the whole country
went in panic
uh yes pete there was riots there was
people dying there's there's
massive civil unrest is that isn't that
crazy that some guy can be like oh that
that currency we have
it's now a different currency and
everyone just believes it everything in
india is pretty much cash
uh except for some places in delhi and
when i was in delhi it was fine i went
to goa
everything's in cash which was
absolutely absurd during a currency
reset
where people were sleeping outside of
atms there was tourists
they had it was also weird to see atm
segregated for
local indians and tourists and the
tourists were literally sleeping outside
the indians lines were even
way longer because people didn't have
any money didn't have any cash
oh because they raised the currency they
got rid of a
large swap of currency because the
government wanted all the accounting
because a lot of people because it's
such a cash driven
country a lot of people have their money
figure regularly underneath the mattress
the government was like you're not
paying taxes on that so we're just gonna
make all of these bills illegal
you're gonna have to give them to us so
we could see exactly how much you have
so we could get you the accurate amount
of money that you owe the government uh
crazy time during the currency reset and
then this crazy story but
we got it we got to keep it on i know
but one thing that that kind of reverted
to uh in india that was very interesting
was people literally doing an honor
system you go to the store you just tell
them your name
you just take down your name you would
have to come back later pay cash but but
a lot of civil unrest happens in in
india uh
the country geopolitically is at a very
important place especially countering
china
so there's a lot of interest in india
they're stabilizing india right now with
china
china is basically on on the border of
india and they're fighting right well
they're having these weird clashes
without any weapons
like clubs but they're using archaic
weapons like clubs and sticks and nails
and barbed wire on baseball bats
literally of what they're using fighting
each other
because they have this weird peace
treaty where they can't use
firearms against each other and they
can't use live ammunition against each
other
but they could beat the crap out of each
other which they do but
i've heard recently within the last few
days they actually
uh settled previous conflicts that were
arising just
two weeks ago and they're at a stalemate
now so they're at a position where
there's more peace now than
there was just two weeks ago here's
here's the crazy thing about the toolkit
that gets released
you have to ask yourself who who makes
these things who spends the time to
develop
an activist guide for protesting and you
mentioned this
luke you've got intelligence agencies
you think about what's going on with
with china and india and the conflict on
the border plus i mean you have
like what pakistan like kashmir all that
stuff
so there's there's good reason for any
adversary of india or us
to create that conflict so when you have
international interests
spreading information that can
destabilize a country
what did the united states say about it
when we had what was it like
a handful of facebook pages with almost
no followers
created by russia yeah they went for
years claiming russia was trying to take
over the country and destabilize
everything and they were freaking out
in fact they're still freaking out
they're foaming at the mouth like
over over some facebook pages now what
would happen if russia was disseminating
pamphlets booklets toolkits
telling people how to bypass arrest how
to win in the legal system
how to protest how to hashtag how to
spread the ideology and win
they would have gone even crazier it
would be it would
it if you think it was nuts now with
with russiagate imagine if russia
actually put together
a toolkit telling people how to do these
things it didn't get that bad
and they still went insane that's what's
happening in india
and greta tunberg is facilitating it and
she's not indian
look if if you are an american if you
are an indian and you put together an
activist guide because you want to help
people and you believe in your cause
well that's cool yeah aoc did that if
you're a foreign
actor of high profile with tons of money
and massive backing from special
interests and then you are pushing out
ideological and and tactical information
that can exacerbate riots and protests
well now you got a problem
you got a serious problem because what
happens if india actually becomes
destabilized i i wonder if you know
look i kind of feel bad for greta
toomberg because she's just a kid
the things she's called for in terms of
abandoning fossil fuels outright banning
fossil fuels in the next year or
whatever
not even the issue like now we want it
now it'd just kill millions of people
look at what's happening in texas with
these windmills freezing and the gas
lines freezing
we need to make sure we get the
electricity running already
we can see what happens when you do not
have
the sufficient electrical you know
equipment
weathering etc i know a lot of people
are blaming the wind turbines for
freezing but everything basically froze
nobody thought was gonna happen
15 states are having power outages
there's 4.4 million people that went
without power in texas the national
guard had to be deployed right
and there's a huge argument now
happening whether it's the the kind of
free energy or whether it's the
fuels that are you know right right
right right but but just
the basic point with greta tunberg i'm
trying to make is she doesn't understand
the things she's advocating for
are going to kill millions from getting
rid of the fossil fuels fine
but if look if if riots protests
and you know mass protests massive
unrest sweeps india
because the people of india are
challenging their their legal system
oh okay then you know we want to make
sure people stay safe we don't want a
collapse that results in mass death we
want reform we want people to
you know do the right thing and we don't
want fighting in the streets
gratitude doesn't understand what
destabilization or collapse really means
and i don't think she
i don't think i mean i guess she would
care if she knew but i don't think she
knows
i don't think she realizes what it means
for someone of her profile
to be having these conversations
apparently there are like some leaked
messages as well
where she's saying like oh these hate
campaigns they happen
it's like dude the hate campaigns are
happening because you're interfering in
a foreign country's politics
and you have massive clout that's
getting tons of attention
and spreading this artificial you know
external ideology
inside the country so surprised people
are protesting her
these are they're calling it an
international criminal conspiracy man
yeah a lot of eyes are on india and i
think we're going to be hearing about
india a lot more especially in the near
future
especially with their very strategic
very important position in the world
because
as as the china is going to be expanding
their influence they're going to also be
propping up
pakistan these are all nuclear powers
and when you look at india i mean they
have a vast
emerging middle class that speaks
english
that is ready to help even even by some
estimates even by some experts
be the next hegemonic world power even
over
china because they they are in a better
position than
china on the world map uh comparatively
as well so so india is going to be
a very key crucial place to to sway your
influence in especially in the not so
distant future
and uh it's not a surprise that this is
happening to me in my opinion i got
mixed feelings about
uh what what this is all about this
farmer protest now what i'm trying i'm
trying to figure it out too so maybe we
can clarify it
sounds like what they're doing is right
now
uh if if a big multi-national
multi-corporate uh
farming industry in india wanted to sell
bare bottom prices and out
and outmatch all the the local farmers
they could sell their
their corn for three dollars and the
government would have to step in
tim is this is this can you clarify this
i don't know a whole lot okay so what
but they want to
the government would would subsidize it
it's basically right now government
regulated sales versus
absolute free markets so like if general
if monsanto wanted to sell three dollar
corn and the
the farmer was like i can't afford to
sell my corn for three dollars or put me
out of business okay
the government said okay you can sell
your coin for ten dollars we'll
subsidize seven of it and then it'll go
for three dollars to the market
no maybe that sounds like maybe what is
going on right now but they want to
change it so that
government gets out of the way and
corporates can sell whatever but the
danger is
the gist of what we monsanto could
undercut these we don't know that
this is what it sounds like they're pro
sure we don't know that we don't we
don't we don't know that we don't know
that we don't know exactly
the limits of this law it's a foreign
country and i can't tell you i can only
tell you that cnn said
right now the current system is a
government minimum guarantee for crops
versus a
sell to anyone at any price market right
with the sell to anyone model
is could be dangerous because if you
have monsanto over there and they want
to sell three dollar corn and the local
farmers can't afford it
it'll bankrupt local farmers so that's
why government is in there to help
subsidize local farmers
um and and trying to it's never this
simple and we just don't know
it and ultimately maybe it doesn't even
matter what it is it's just that there's
foreign nationals
in fl but i mean that's that's the name
of the game right now the globe is
connected you know
where it's it's not even a national
national game it's the same thing with
china bro
it's it's it's not that america wants
cheaper products made in china
they don't the american people want jobs
they want to be able to work they want
to feel fulfilled
i find it hilarious that we have so many
gen z memes where it's like
there was one where it's from the
incredibles where you know have you guys
seen the incredibles
the family of superheroes yeah so
basically like superheroes are outlawed
and then like this
mr incredible is now an insurance you
know adjuster or whatever
and it said like me there's like a meme
it's like me working in an office
you know getting paid for you know for
an unfulfilling existence or something
and i'm like yeah people want meaningful
jobs they want to make things to be
proud of
but all of those are being shipped away
so these jobs are going to china
why because billionaires because the
billionaires and the millionaires in
this country
that's why now bernie sanders you know
mock him
essentially because he's no longer
fighting against the millionaires and
the billionaires but same thing with
you you mentioned these these companies
the international ties regular people
don't want this stuff
they just want to be with their families
they want to make enough they want to
get by they want to survive
they don't want to boot on their neck
from the government and they don't want
their
their jobs being sent overseas thanks
for checking out this clip from the tim
cast irl podcast
if you want to see the full show come
back to this channel youtube.com
tim cast irl monday through friday at
8pm where you can leave comments
and super chat and we actually will read
your comments
on the show don't forget to like share
subscribe and if you want exclusive
members only content segments you can't
get anywhere else
go to timcast.com become a member and we
even have full bonus episodes
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time
you